president Trump's spending the holiday
weekend at his Resort in Florida and
while the president's trying to keep his
administration looking forward there are
many who are still fascinated and
haunted by the past correspondent Peter
Doocy is in West Palm Beach tonight good
evening Peter
good evening Shannon we've just heard a
rare concession from a Clinton the 2016
Democratic nominee who once wrote a book
called living history now wishes she
could rewrite some of her own
disparaging comments about Trump
supporters but she's not saying sorry
and she's not going anywhere in the heat
of battle and political back-and-forth
I've said things that you know I would
like to take back but that doesn't mean
Clinton is done complaining about her
failed campaign now she's accusing
anyone advising her to leave 2016 in the
past of being sexist I was really struck
by how people said that to me you know
mostly people in the press for whatever
reason like oh you know go away go away
and I had a one of the young people
works for me go back and do a bit of
research they never said that to any man
who was not elected the White House is
scoffing at Clinton's claims of gender
bias she's wrong comparing herself to
those male candidates Republican and
Democratic who lost presidential
elections as well they were much more
gracious about it
a famous Democrat who has been keeping a
much lower profile this year is set to
help candidates cash in former President
Obama reportedly ready to campaign for
Senator Claire McCaskill at a fundraiser
in California so the 44th president is
getting ready for the midterms
just like the 45th who is now testing
out a new campaign pitch for
infrastructure you probably have to wait
till after the election
because the Democrats say don't give him
any more wins the special counsels
office isn't ready to look ahead though
2016 is still the focus for Robert
Muller whose collusion probe appears to
be honing in on former campaign aide
Rick Gates and his contacts with a
Russian spy but on the other side of the
aisle FBI forces who are allegedly eager
to help Clinton beat Trump are under a
new microscope themselves with the
Attorney General Jeff Sessions
announcing that instead of a second
special counsel he'll have US Attorney
for Utah John Huber probe for wrongdoing
at the DOJ but pressures on to produce
if he does his job really well and
really aggressively people will relax if
he doesn't do his job you'll see a whole
new demand for a second independent
counsel so as lesser known Democrats
tried to dip their toes into the pool of
2020 contenders to gain traction or
shape talking points the 2016 election
is still being relitigated and the most
prominent Democrats still talking about
it is Hillary Clinton Shannon Peter
Doocy in West Palm Beach thank you Peter